le million d'euros
voilà
une énorme occasion que pendant trois
jours se défoncer pour une belle oeuvre
caritative et honnêtement ça fait
plaisir ça fait du bien
la communauté incroyable cette année
incroyable talent ou pas je te remercie
beaucoup ce rythme est chaud c'est
maintenant une affaire continent voilà
l'événement ça de la meilleure image du
streaming
à
ça y est le zii event vient tout juste
d'être lancé l'escrimeur sont passés en
live sur foot est leur objectif ça être
pendant les deux prochains jours de
lever le plus d'argent possible pour
action contre la faim la
nation merci fraga ponte 4,093 eller au
bordel j pour prouver ton de 1000 euros
là
parce qu'il faut savoir c'est que tous
les streamers qu'on appelle un tony chan
goal ça veut dire un objectif de dons et
à chaque fois ce sont des paliers ça
peut être dix mille euros cinquante
mille euros cent mille euros voire
beaucoup plus pour certains d'aidé qui
passe ces paliers ils ont un gage où il
doit faire une action la mode avec des
machines de là à 1,5 milles où je devais
me changer en caus mesure oui square
ça tiendra jamais associé 22 serait
votre princesse
tous les minéraux compass je vais avec
ça et unique point
c'est bizarre
deux cent mille euros fut paris
marseille à pied les rues sa copine je
vais pas que c'est avec ce genre d'offre
pierre qui donne 7 euros pour les gens
dans le besoin donc là les gars os et
action contre la faim l'association
excusez moi de vous déranger
annonce assez importantes s'étaient pas
revus depuis assez longtemps mais vous
avez été planté le module de donation
merci appelé
envoimoinscher communication exprime là
le stream de notre partenaire qui
récupère les dons avant que ça passe par
d'autres plateformes pour aller dans la
graisse de l'assaut et donc à un module
de dons alloués et on l'a déjà fait
sauter en
30 minutes ça veut dire qu'il ya
tellement de connexion et de gens qui
font des donc la charge serveur est pas
prise par le site et que du coup tout
exploser comme un tueur maintenant c'est
la merde mais on va essayer de régler ça
je pense que ça va le faire après la
marche pas parce que c'est les gars
sarlat respect pour lui
vingt mille euros mais que j'ai compté
les héros pour vérifier que ce n'est
plus le bon chiffre là pour vous donner
un ordre d'idée quasiment toutes les
demi-heures il passe un palier de cent
mille euros c'est complètement vain que
ça va très très vite bon va être baigné
très tôt
on
va dire qu'il aya le port à droite donc
c'est le port de bora bora
tout frais mais ce dossier mais pas des
professionnels
chaude
il est temps il est temps là on voit les
vagues
donc là tout le long du week-end il faut
faire des jeux tous ensemble par exemple
ils sont en train de jouer à paul caille
et l'objectif c'est d'être le dernier
survivant
et casser vos plus tard
verissimo évidemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur les sept
[Musique]
craquer
yakhya
la salle est en train de se transformer
en cours de récré géantes c'est énorme
ici opération buisson je répète nous
sommes entre la porte et pas
je n'arrive pas à savoir qui est là
dessus
nous
sommes
pas
rocchi man
bisous mais ils sont à deux doigts de
passer le million d'euros récoltés dès
le premier soir que l'année dernière
c'était le samedi à 19h30 clairement ils
sont en train de battre un énorme encore
plus cette débauche les gars 1 01 euro
merci les gars ont contribué aux
millions
ce n'est pas plus non millions d'euros
il ya un truc très marrant qui va se
passer juste derrière moi dans ce ring
en fait il ya mort quand charrière qui
est un combattant professionnel de mma
qui est venu pour affronter cas métaux
un streamer sauf que cam eto'o est pas
du tout au courant on va nous manquer
tant que nous atteignons passé genk il
va se dire rien
bien
ben
brik il est fatigant même mettre des
coups dans le front froid 2
[Musique]
à la can
j'ai gagné de la monte en l'air gagner
un bon temps
ding ning j'ai vu le point était déjà là
avant moi j'essaie de mettre des coups
j'ai pu y avait aucun dégât c'est la fin
de la première soirée ya déjà beaucoup
de streamer qui sont partis se coucher
même s'il y en a quelques-uns qui vont
rester pour assurer le marathon la
plupart veulent garder des forces parce
que c'est demain que les choses
sérieuses commencent
[Musique]
je le fais manger pour pas tus parce que
presque tous les jeux sans faire exprès
allez vas-y ok c'est bon
ça brûle vas-y vas-y crocs
t'as vu ça mais un petit punch mais les
coûts les saveurs n'a pas apprécié il ya
rien de gros
ça passe un peu dans ça va on attend
c'est pire en pire la highway ça va
aller mais c'est là on fait sécher
l'étrange bois ton truc suis bien mais
quand je lis plus
[Rires]
les gens ont tendance à associer les
piments piquant alors qu'il ya un coup
derrière tout ça et oui faut pas
s'arrêter aux épines alors tous les ans
il ya toujours un peu les vétérans qui
reviennent à chaque édition il y a
à chaque fois mister nv en général
moment alpha caste giraille à domingo
gotaga qui reviendront souvent magna et
il ya aussi beaucoup de nouveaux cette
année notamment robes des terres et
amine petit carton dans ce moment sur
twitter avec des live notamment en
extérieur je sais pas du tout ce qu'ils
ont prévu cette année mais à mon avis
dans l'air très chaud donc ils vont
faire pas mal de conneries
[Applaudissements]
avec seront contents d'être en première
année que je le fais déjà j'ai vu j'ai
vu l'arbitré était refait donc l'
objectif c'est mettre le feu on va
s'amuser ces 220 dans la cagnotte est au
bout de 100 mains en moins de gens
s'améliore pour des commandes est bien
sûr un des gros bras
[Applaudissements]
sans malice ans c'est du rapide en
continu
[Applaudissements]
contre ce soir histoire aux collèges
ok là il ya des gens qui sont un peu
arrivé j'ai des nouvelles images
mais c'est au final
c'est trop tard l'ambiance cas ici avec
tous les escrimeurs je peux parler avec
tout le monde tout le monde est du même
gay mais tout c'est de la frappe frappe
de ouf j'avais déjà rencontré genre 2 3
personnes et là j'ai pu en rencontrer
une trentaine de plus c'est c'est
l'occasion de ce troll et s'est incliné
en vrai et c est entre que derrière un
écran et ça fait vraiment plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur vous dit merci lien merci
magali pour les acteurs ou un soda pour
les commerciaux à découvert pour les
neurones
mais samedi soir il est 19h30 et les
dons sont en train de monter très très
très vite ils vont dépasser les 2
millions d'euros merci on va les
atteindre c'est au client il est
quasiment dix mille euros
journée
[Applaudissements]
tombé
je me concentre juste sur ce que je dois
faire dans ma tête c'est à dire arrêter
de bouger comme une merde pas couper la
parole à samuel être heureux je suis en
panique ça va être compliqué
le capitaine
comme pour l'édition précédente cette
année il ya le journaliste et
présentateur samuel etienne qui a percé
depuis à peu près un an sur twitch qui
est venu pour présenter une émission qui
s'appelle question pour un streamer
question pour un streamer de c'est
extrêmement simple qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un quiz de culture générale en 3
pas préparé par étoiles quelle est la
capitale du sri lanka
mais c'est toi qui présente ici en
fait quand je m'ennuie sur tweets je
vais la france pareil
je fais mes études à la haute école de
musique de varsovie avant de quitter la
pologne à 21 ans pianiste
chopin oui c'est ça c'est ça
champion de l'édition 2021 et jacky
antoine daniel
le g20 et les streamer et papy samcon
escrime touche un public qui est pas
forcément sur les médias traditionnels
passer des messages positifs comme la
solidarité la lutte contre la pauvreté
avec action pour la france c'est hyper
puissant phare donner des dons dans la
description vous pouvez y aller comme
l'a dit robail on a commencé à lancer
l'appel aux dons s'est monté ultra vip
fazul haq des bijoux on est sur une
bonne lancée c'est maintenant une enfant
conçu hors quel va être le premier prix
qui va tomber vous allez ça met une
pression que vous avez ça mérite bien ce
magnifique magnifique tableau l'attend
50 balles chez coca cola une jusqu'ici
mais il bal dj adjugé vendu presse 1708
en 1708 euros les anciens on me permet
d'intégrer les nouveaux et on fait un
truc que moi je trouve vraiment
exceptionnel ils ont été hyper créatif
cette année ils sont tous super
entraînés ils ont tous participé au truc
les uns des autres alors que parfois ils
se connaissent pas tant que ça et c'est
un peu le but de l'événement c'est de
créer des featurings inattendue je
pensais pas que je raccrocherai autant
avec certaines personnes et tout et je
sais que une fois l'événement fini
j'aurais qu'une envie c'est dans les
semaines mois suivant faire des trucs
des projets avec ces personnes là
la plupart des streamers son parti se
coucher parce qu il est 4h30 du matin
mais il ya un petit groupe
d'irréductibles qui a décidé de lancer
un karaoke mama
jo demain
ou
de gana guèye cissé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allah
à
atta
[Applaudissements]
le karaoké vient de se terminer c'est
que maintenant que ça commence à se
calmer un peu dans la salle
et tourne mais une période de flottement
où on est entre 5 et 10 et c'est le
moment que j'adore uzi even parce que
c'est calme en fait j'ai plus la joie de
[ __ ] le bordel
le matin la nuit c'est chez moi c'est
pour vous c'est la nuit pour moi c'est
le début d'après midi
john charles jeune charly jeune charlie
watts en vain genre on s'en va loin ah
non mais attendez il ya un autre
streamer là bas mais qu'est-ce qui fait
c'est sûr qu'il a l'air bien je pense
que c'est vraiment le meilleur contenu
qu'on n'a jamais vue aussi event
jalousie dormir en live bas en vrai la
vienne réveiller je suis plutôt en forme
tu avais je sens que j'ai fait une très
bonne sieste mais je dis la vérité je
vais aller à l'hôtel je vais m'endormir
après
cinq ans comprend pas comment il fait
je viens de commencer je n'ai pas encore
vu mon café soyez indulgents c'est vous
il faut les gens le matin il faut les
jambes ce soir et nous on est on est là
7 heures du matin on était prêts
maintenant y'a plus qu'a annoncé le live
tu as pu un euro aux férus 27 euros ici
ça donne directement dès le début de
journée ce comme j'aime bien on est
dimanche matin il sera 2 doit passer les
3 millions d'euros récoltés ils se sont
mal l'égard de ses tournées à 150 livres
ou 5 et 3 millions les trois [ __ ] de
millions
85 ans l'ordinateur tout pavé sur
l'ordinateur
bravo à toutes et tous la journée
s'annonce folle parce qu'au 3 millions
déjà ils ont pas encore a ajouté la
vente en ligne des t-shirts du civ n
2021 et ça représente tous les ans au
moins plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'euros voire au moins un million
d'euros donc c'est un chiffre énorme
qu'il faudra ajouter à la cagnotte et en
fin de journée il y aura ce qu'on
appelle le grand rush ou tous les
streamer vont inviter leurs viewer à
faire un maximum de dons et en général
les gens il garde beaucoup de donc pour
ce moment là pour essayer de battre le
record de l'année précédente donc ça va
être fou pour les construire quelque
chose vous les cueillir des baies j'ai
un petit j'ai tout ce qu'il faut donc
bien j'aimerais pec pec l'époque la
salle heidi wood un des bouillides
adidas voilà vous l'aviez u10 dadou la
musique officielle c'est pour bientôt
le gold et 150000 euros récoltés pour
l'association du coup l'on part sur à un
petit atout qui va me rappeler les world
qui ont été gagnés savoir zéro mais
c'est inoubliable ça c'est incroyable
incroyable
c'est un seul événement 12 mois jeudi à
200% tu vois j'essaie de donner le
maximum et rage chez vous on va aller
mais je pense que ya de fortes chances
que tous les record soit battu cette
année
c'est qu'un mec qui va avoir envie de la
caméline
occupé de toi mais
kamal lahlou pas ça va non c'est pas mal
non mais j'ai gardé le vrai champion né
dans les années 60 13 oui oui c'est ça
la pour la seule l'ag plus que cela pour
une touche la tondeuse
quand la france c'est vous c'est beau le
record français c'est vous je sais pas
pour un j'ai vu ça ils conformes je suis
choqué bien craignent de la de l'adn de
la lassitude chez jamais vu ça je suis
choquée mais c'est incroyable c'est
maintenant ou jamais le connais donné
donné
90 balle merci beaucoup pour mon pc à
crach à cause des dons baissent
les enfants tentent de réparer les
boeufs on paie sa marche plabennec c'est
les aléas ça me fait une pause en
réponse à mme mais bien celle là depuis
10 heures et puis de toute façon presque
et robin ancien veulent c'est que paul
et sur les lacs de tout le monde que
même si tourlaville marche pas tant pis
ça me fait plaisir ce soir
[Applaudissements]
sa passion moi je dis on peut essayer
d'aller taper des six sept ans on va
faire de notre mieux les gens aussi je
pense donc pour bien voir galali droite
on va faire sortir tous les rats de
france on va faire casquer tous les rats
de compte ce soir on le savait chaque
année nous entendons des t-shirts pour
l'asie est bonne et nous allons
puisqu'il est 20h en faire une première
révélation de combien ces t-shirts ont
rapporté le chiffre à la plagne en t2
[Applaudissements]
assimilant 617 ville record de l'an
dernier battue
ouais
on a mené dans le cadre d'un débat
[Applaudissements]
ouais
inside pensais pas qu on dépasserait
autant le record de l'année dernière et
c'est pas fini il reste un quart ya
quelqu'un qui n'a pas pu être ici ce
soir et qui voulaient venir aussi et
vote ses squeeze qui vient de faire un
don de 40 mille euros à une octave merci
à beaucoup à lui
[Musique]
est bien mignonne
mitterrand salue c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est la folie sont tous en train de se
remettre ça veut dire qu'ils sont tous
en train de s'entre aider à remplir les
cagnottes de chacun et ça donne des
sanitaires émouvante
quel bordel à
[Applaudissements]
alors
là bas
[Applaudissements]
viennent de dépasser un million d'euros
maintenant ça défile donc il y a plus
qu'à attendre le résultat final
mais voilà et pas sur place et l'avenir
cette année elle est là 108 euros il ya
eu 7 euros 5 euros
100 euros or alive explose la cagnotte
merci d'un journal est devenu merci
beaucoup et s'il est devenu le jeune
homme continue elle part en mission
humanitaire et avec moi tu viens avec
moi puis centrafricaine négation de la
fin elle vient avec moi c'est trop bien
cinquante mille euros royal j'ai eu deux
jours françois fillon on y va tu as le
droit à tracfin en plus
c'est du jamais vu c'est du jamais vu 9
millions si cela ils savent à une
vitesse incroyable on arrive à lire ça
va trop vite ces débats vous vous
trouvez
[Applaudissements]
ouais
on est dans les dernières minutes de
choisy even 2021 tout l'argent pour
récolter ses extraordinaires merci à
lenox fais-nous rêver lot un t3
à chasser les souris on va tout et
blattes et là on a le temps de chypre
tee shirt après je vous laisse
tranquille reichel combat à gratter
à
[Musique]
là
-
calais toujours à mons tournai merci
d'exister
c'est même une reddition de l'histoire
quel pays il ya tout qui s'est passé
mieux que ça devait être prévu et moi de
mon côté avec ma communauté
on a des souvenirs de fou qu'on a gardé
de cet événement incroyable et je pense
que lens après avoir après avoir dû ça
on peut sans qui
la toile boss de la nuit la bosse de la
nuit là j'ai un besoin d'être en fin de
soirée genre mais jean fin de soirée
enfin daft gentilles et 17h on a hâte a
fait 2-2 20 heures à 17 heures avec mes
habits sécurité tu sais c'est un
week-end comme les autres j'ai pas envie
de te dire un week-end comme les autres
tu dis millions d'euros quoi on verra ce
qu'on fera la prochaine toi quoi tout
simplement non ces informations
c'était quand même un peu quand même
hein chaque année je pars un peu ce que
ça repoussera c'est pas pu si au fond on
a la meilleure communauté du monde c'est
extraordinaire
regardez
ces petits manchots les jours sans
merci à laurent blanc a extraordinaire
et merci merci encore des milliards de
fois vous tous puisque évidemment nous
on trime on est bien beau mais il avait
tellement donné on a donné notre temps
vous avez tellement donné c'était
extraordinaire merci à tous je réalise
pas encore je pense que dans trois
quatre jours je dis ça va redescendre et
de parole alors c'était incroyable
justement meyer the event vraiment de
cette année c'était
sur les 3 et humaine que j'ai choisi
mon frérot quelle aventure de fous je
suis complètement déglingué on a tout
donné apparemment ces trois le cd v est
le plus drôle à faire et j'ai messi trop
à viser 10 millions c'est d'un gris jeu
j'ai même pas les mots tellement les
gens soupçons des rois tenait il faut
tomber leur couronne tenir mettez votre
couronne sur la tête tout le monde
puisque tous ont participé de près ou de
loin à cet événement
pareil primo je raconterai ça mes
enfants je tu vois des gens chez eux ils
ont 1 4 moi j'aurai un tableau nfd
digital avait que des clips d'user des
rebelles tribaux c'est comme ça fait
petit revenu c'est comme ça je vais leur
montrer rires je me rappellerai
habitants bah voila j'ai jamais eu ma
voix cassée malvy carrément suis très
ému et très fier d'avoir pu participer à
éclater autant d'argent pour une ong qui
rend qui méritent pas qu'ils méritent
par son action et par action pour les
gens d'action tard et
et voilà ça ça dit quelque chose là ça
nous ça nous rend fiers semrau humble et
j'espère que ça que le message passe
aussi dans le cerveau de tout le monde
veut dire que ben ouais la solidarité
sera de l'avenir et que le streaming ça
représente quelque chose c'est pas un
adepte du tout quand je vois toutes les
gens tous les gens qui sont différents
et qui viennent de milieux sociaux
différents qui se regroupent et qui
arrive à faire ça tous ensemble avec des
personnes qui sont derrière leur écran
et qui s'identifient à toutes ces
personnes qui sont si différents bah moi
je crois que c'est ça l'unité en fait
j'étais très aggravant surpris les gens
ont été fous les gens ont été foudroyées
de partout 10 millions on a presque fait
le double de l'année dernière se passe
il rendait compte qu'on pensait déjà
impossible à battre l'as pulver aulas
pulver
c'était fou et sais pas quoi dire
c'est à ce titre
que 13
millions c'est fini [ __ ] on l'a fait
je sais pas trop comment énergie
incroyable je suis mort regarde film ça
regarde ça
on a remis en plus retenir ouais bravo
et encore bravo incroyable
c'est un truc de ouf
clap de fin
mais voilà mais ces tissus heures en
fait c'était sûr
[Musique]